hello these are conspiracies alberto
in the first episode we saw how
we can use the def tools to put
hand to the code of a web page is like
we can save it directly in the file
source via a feature of
chrome called workspaces in this
instead we'll see how we can
emulate other devices and how
we can connect remotely for
example to this the cell phone here and
then paying the code that is there
actually turning over
let's see then what our neighbor is
task what we are asked to
make less responsive or to do
so that it works properly too
on mobile devices
in fact if we go to decrease the
window size we can
see that the menu items go
below the bar which is not
exactly the behavior that
we also want we are asked to
check a certain functionality
that is activated with the changes of
orientation directly on the screen
but we see this in a second
time to make less responsive
so let's use media quiri that
briefly they are expressions that
we can add to our css code
it is based on a certain
condition apply new ones
property in this case we have one
class was that applies a border of a
pixel is when ours
device has a maximum width
of 600 pixels
this class will also apply one
then 100 percent width
back to our application is like
we want to do
we want to make sure that when the
screen width and for example of
at most 500 pixels all elements
of the menu will be hidden inside
of a drop-down menu so let's go into the
source code
then we have the html page
so my name is the drop-down menu
we also activate the viewport meta tag which
causes the application to come
all rendered inside the
screen and then here with my media query
that active
refresh the page now is not
still nothing changed though us
we decrease the width of the screen
here is the drop-down menu with
all the elements inside then
decrease the chrome window is one
of the ways in which we can verify i
changes of how ours works
application according to the different ones
screen size a size
another way we have and this in i
developer tools if I don't go out first
activate the console
we have a new panel that does
they call ration where we can precisely
emulate our device
in this case for example can
decide to emulate the dimensions of the
screen with a resolution of 320 x 480
if I apply it, I must see that here
the screen has been reduced precisely from
320 x 480 and can scroll mine
application inside
anyway let's see how now
how the app works in a
real device starting from android 4
we have the possibility to waive the
code that runs directly on ours
android device
to do this we can use
this extension of chrome allows
to make the remote connection
this extension adds this to us
button with aldo that if
we apply and start this
charge here is the attack on
my phone with chrome has opened
inside you see this is recognized
and if I'm going to make a target action
here it is here to do it
now
here is where I can upload with then
I start directly on the website
as you can see now chrome is a page
google pico open both for mine
application and you see that here is already the
menu as we wanted it here I can do
inspect and the tools are opened
related to the application I have
opened at this time among other things a
very interesting feature that was
introduced now in chrome canary e
soon we will also see in the version of
chrome and the screencast that allows me
to see in real time what
what appears in my device
see right now I'm standing
scrolling the page on the desktop e
the behavior is replicated on
good cell phone now we can go to
see the other tusk that was there
requested or that relating to
small screen orientation
problem i'm the requa i don't have the
orientation sensor that comes to me
recognized by chrome so one thing
what can I do is come back with here
and simulate orientation with this one
property of the sensor here what
practically happens when I ride
when I turned the phone and if
I take slides canelli put
in the belt the belt comes to me
emptied when the phone is turned of
90 degrees
in this case I can try to simulate
the celer ometro and to turn of 90 degrees
the range then hungry and rich program
as you see now, my word appears to me
the alert for the belt was
empty
said this
see which the next request
now they are pointing out to us that
this button only downloads one
shuriken at a time in the belt
now we want to make sure that every
once we press it they don't come
loaded one hundred at a time
so now I don't remember where the
code that is executed when however
this button one thing I can do
is to highlight it so only here in the
panel elements I can go to events
listeners equa to the click event
if I open this item I can see
that the code that is executed yes
find it here
this is the function that is inside the
my gs file and see what it does
perform this function I can go
directly to modify it except business
I also change the element instead of
take one take on android
now the page we will know the
button loads 100 items
in the belt
we will see that it is the last change that
we did will have an impact on
performance of our application in
particular we will observe dips of
therefore we will see which tools
we have available to identify
and solve this kind of problems